I talk about the volume of pain there
are times when
it's so intense when the volume is so
high that I just wish somebody would
come along and unzip my body and just
take it away
humankind has constantly tried to Define
pain it's
[Music]
most of the pains that we feel are
day-to-day and they do resolve they're
part of our bodies protection making us
rest and protect the area and make sure
it doesn't get infected if it's a wound
and so day-to-day pain may be kind of
annoying but it is really important a
life without pain would be very
dangerous and life-threatening
so if I were to
tell you how how my pain is at the
moment it actually feels
today is if someone's trying to put a
wetsuit on me but this wetsuit is just
covered in tiny attacks that are really
really sharp and they're pulling on this
wetsuit all the time it also feels as if
there are people with drills on the
soles of my feet and there are lots lots
and lots of people and they're they're
just drilling into my feet and my legs
feel really tight as if someone's got
giant hands that are just really really
squeezing
oh
so neuropathic pain is really intense
it's experienced as almost real
events like being pinched and squeezed
very severe what feel like electrical
pulses and clinical experts in pain are
able to right away identifying
neuropathic pain because of these awful
descriptors the last kind of pain the
Third Kind of Pain is really the mystery
and that is the existence of pain for
which there is no obvious origin
so that does not in any way mean that it
isn't real it's 100 real it's just that
our understanding of our bodies is
limited at the moment and you can't find
an injury
so we're left with a population of
people who are really suffering from
Pain and it interferes with their life
but we don't understand where it comes
from
[Music]
thank you
pain itself is a hidden disability and I
think it's really difficult to get that
across because you can't see somebody
else's pain I suppose in
every Walk of Life if you feel
understood that's half the battle and I
think that
journey of trying to explain yourself
is a really hard one it it's absolutely
exhausting
when you don't feel believed it has such
a massive effect on your mental
well-being that living with that
pressure is almost just as hard as the
pain and well why should people
understand if they haven't experienced
it but also there is the word compassion
and you're hoping that there might be
more compassion around
I think the outstanding mystery is why
is it that a substantial
number of our population are suffering
from Pain without any obvious biological
purpose
[Music]
I'm not sure that in in my lifetime
there's going to be a magic potion that
suddenly will take all the pain away but
I think the more that we all talk about
it that's where I feel hopeful that's
where I can do my little bit that's the
optimistic bit other people wear all the
nails and the screwdrivers and the
drills and my feet will go I don't know
but I have to believe that I will find
my way forward
foreign
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video